so I'm sitting here at a Boston hotel
room wondering why am I so pumped what
am I like so giddy about and I realized
it's because I'm about to go and speak
in front of 200 people don't do a live
Wine Library TV and it just reminds me
of out of all the things I do the
consulting work for marketing for
companies sitting on boards you know
Wine Library TV wine library the retail
side all the crazy stuff that I do the
thing that gets me most excited and most
hyped is to go and speak at conferences
and do live wine lebra TVs and these
book signing things because I just love
people and you know a lot of people in
one place is even more exciting to me
and one other thing that I think really
gets me excited is that I really like to
speak to the audience about what they
want to know about I think way too many
people when they do conferences do the
same speech or spend the whole time
talking about what they did which is
great and I think for somebody like me
that a lot of people don't know it's
important because it gives a backstory
but I think it's imperative that you're
like chameleon and you give the kind of
talk that the people the audience need
you know sometimes I do conferences for
industries that have nothing to do with
wine and they want to learn about social
media and I cater it towards that I
think it's imperative you've got to
speak to the people that are in the
audience you know you can't bring a
hockey stick to a basketball court and
way too many people out there speaking
at conferences are doing that and so I
know a lot of you are putting together
proposals for South by Southwest and
other conferences just remember think
about the demo that's there and make it
the most valuable possible for them my
number one goal is that the people that
invited me to speak are thrilled with me
when I do speak